Voted the best podcast of all time. I had a laugh riot. Smartless brings all the laughs when three friends, Jason Bateman, Sean Hayes, and Will Arnett, get together and just chop it up and spit it out. It's smartless and it's, wait, am I not doing an ad for the, no? It's just a, it's a cold open. Okay. You're listening to smartless. Smart. Less.
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure.
I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure.
I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I don't like anything. You don't like anything. Third, Will was third today. No, I was, that's not true. Technically second.
I was third. Practically second, but technically third because Sean was here earlier. You know what, you know what? I thought that I had more time and I went and I actually, I went to the same guy that Sean did who helped him with his carpal tunnel, Tarek, and he, so I was standing on a rack.
Don't drop Tarek's name in hopes of getting a break on your medical bill from him, okay? That was pathetic. Jason, have you ever gone to him? Let's have the last name too. Go ahead. Jason, have you been to him? Yes, I have.
Yes, I have. Oh, you have now. He's incredible. Oh, yeah. Oh, really? So why don't you want to? Well, yeah, I had a bad back at some point. Tarek Godra.
Still do, but- Tarek Godra, he helped to lean. And he- So he's great, And here comes your discount. So I was standing on a, the reason I was late, I was standing on a racquetball. Cause as you know, I have a bad, I had to bail out.
Toe? From my hamstring last week. I had to bail out of golf memory. You and I were with Charlie and Robin. And it got so bad. And he said that there was like basically like buildup on my hamstring around my sciatic nerve. Fuck man, I couldn't even sit down.
Is it better now? Yeah, so how's it going? Much better, he's helped it out a lot. Yeah, so what do you gotta do now to maintain it? He made you stand on a racquetball, that fixed it? Yeah, that was part of it. No, it was, you know, my posture was terrible. You know, pillow under your knees when you sleep.
How you sit, all this kind of stuff. Anything about eating cereal for dinner? He said, he said double down. Oh, did he? He said double down on that. And instead of milk, ice cream, like a real soft, soft, soft serve ice cream and cereal. Sean just got a boner.
Sean, can I ask you a question? So earlier, earlier this morning, before I record here, just, just half hour ago, I'm on a business call, right, because it's a work day. Oh, we're up with a business call. Yeah, a business call. And so I couldn't take the incoming phone call
from Mr. Arnett, right? Yeah, okay. Just let it go to voicemail. Hang up the business call, check my voicemail. There's no message. Just a record that he's called. Is that what he does with you? Like some, that just won't leave a message, you know?
Because like he's trying to hide the fact that he tried to call and then I didn't pick up. And so he's like too embarrassed to leave a message. No, but do you leave a message? I never leave a message either. Of course I leave a message. Or at least I'll text afterwards and say, hey, tried you. Yeah, well, I'll do that sometimes,
but the call is the message. No, it's not enough that there's just a recent call from you. That doesn't qualify. You got to leave me a message if you want to call back. Oh, God. Honestly, no offense to Chris Berman at ESPN, but I think your new nickname might be Boomer. So listen, Boomer, here's the deal. I will say this.
What we do now is we don't leave messages because there's a record that I called, and so you can decide whether or not. That's your message. That's the message. So that's official? Or were you just trying to hide the fact that you're stalking me like some kind of wounded, wounded ex-boyfriend of mine? Hey, by the way, do you think I wanted to talk to you?
I had to ask you something. Well, is it, let's have a nap. Look at this attitude, do you think I want to deal with this? Right, well, is it, text it. It's like imagine a smile. No, because it's easier. To Jason's credit, yeah.
Jason, to your credit, I will always text you, hey, do you got a second? Or you, hey, I want to chat with you. Right, exactly. And you call me right away. You're just doing how I days will. You call me almost. Well, I was just trying, you know what?
You know what? I was just trying to get, I was just trying to make it easy and streamline it. And I was trying to cold call you. Yeah, because we have a relationship that was established on calling years ago. When did we decide that we were gonna text first? I didn't get that text.
Now that I got you all warmed up, and you're up in the first round, let's go out there and meet our fighter. Fucking, who we got, Arnett? By the way, our buddy Bradley got seven Oscar nominations for most of his films. Wait, he did? He should have got director Goddammit.
That's the best directed film of the last decade. I agree. I agree. It's fucking, it's unbelievable. Rice that movie. Listener, there is no better film this year than my show. Full stop. Full stop.
If you, to do what he did with that film is so incredible. An impossible target. It's so different. Nobody's doing anything like that. Yeah, when I first saw it, I was blown away. It's a stunning piece of work. And I hope he takes solace in the fact
that the Academy will probably look at this and Star is Born as, okay, he did it twice really, really well. So this next one, we're gonna twice really, really well. So this next one, we're going to give him at least a nomination if not the statue. It'd be great if they did it for the next one. Oh yeah, exactly, Willie. So that would be great.
That would be nice. Willie's got one coming up with, Bradley. So speaking of the Academy Awards, our fellow seems to got himself an Academy Award nomination. Today? Yeah, not today, but he has had Academy... I looked at his... He's one of those guys who's got his own award nomination page on Wikipedia because there's so many that they can't even fit in his regular page. I'm getting nervous.
Same goes with his filmography. It's got its own fucking page, which most of the times it would bum you out, but with this guy, it's okay. Cause he's one of the good dudes. And he has done stuff, I mean, you're gonna remember a lot of this stuff. Johnny Betts from Private Eye, Taylor Rolater from 21 Jump Street. You might know him as Glenn from Finish Line.
You might know him as Jack Passion from Mwonekka Road. Probably, probably not, but you might know him more as Gurney Halleck from Dune, or Thanos from Avengers Endgame, or Dan White for which he was nominated for an Academy Award for 2008's Milk. Guys, it's the unbelievably talented, the explosion that is my favorite JB, Josh Brolin.
Oh, Josh. Oh yeah. Oh, Josh. It was just talking about you this morning. Dude, when you started that resume, I go, what the fuck did? The stuff you tried to bury. What is he doing?
Yeah. Dude, it's all there. Bro, I've come to all the things that you've never seen and don't remember. Welcome our guest. No, I mean, if he just said Goonies, I would have guessed it in two seconds. Well, fuck, I didn't want to say Goonies
because I was trying to go old first. And so if I said Goonies, fucking Sean would have gone, ee, it's time, bro! Josh, does Goonies follow you around like Teen Wolf 2 follows me around? Yeah, but how proud of Teen Wolf for you. Right? Honestly.
But no, but thank God, both of those... There was a point with Goonies where it was like, please God, give me another movie, any movie that anybody will see. But Goonies was a great film. Teen Wolf 2 had its challenges. It wasn't for trying. But thank God it has turned into just kitsch in our resume, right? But it's not just Teen Wolf two, it's Teen Wolf also.
I just want to make the right guess. Yeah, T double L, okay? This is not a sequel, right? I wouldn't dare. I don't know, Josh. Are they gonna do another one? Do you get that? Yeah, Teen Wolf three and three D.
It's in deep development right now. Three and three D. Who's better than Josh Brolin? Look at this. I am so psyched to settle in with JB. I am so psyched you're here, dude. So nice to meet you. Let's start with what you guys met on the set of what was that?
What was it? Well, we met before a little bit, but we both, I didn't want to bring up the Razzie-nominated Jonah Hex. Wow. Did it get a Razzie? Why don't you tell the story, if you're willing to tell the story, tell the story that you've told me
when you over at my house one day, you told me that you were walking by my trailer and what did you see? Do you remember this? It was the end of a long day. We were shooting this scene where we came into, we were on horseback. Do you remember that, Josh in that park
and they set up the old town? And John Gallagher and I came in leading, I did not know how to ride a horse. They taught me, wrote in the town. Anyway, so it was like a dusty day. We'd been on horseback all day and I walked by and Josh had this incredible makeup for Jonah Hex that took hours to put on.
He could barely move, he could speak out of one side of his mouth. The other one had this prosthetic on that took forever. And then had a hole in the prosthetic. So I couldn't. And a hole in the prosthetic. So I walked by his trailer and it's like 6 p.m. We've been shooting 12 hours as hot as fucking New Orleans,
like a thousand degrees. And Josh is sitting on the steps of his trailer with a cigarette sticking out of the hole of his presser. And I had to put a finger over the hole in order to be able to inhale the cigarette. And I had, what else could I have? And he was holding a bottle of whiskey. Makers mark.
He was holding a bottle of Makers mark in his fucking hand drinking. At 11 o'clock in the morning. It sounded like he had a triple banger too, or a double banger. It was a little later than that, but it was. And the fact that I blame Jonah Hex on anybody else is a fucking joke
I Gotta see that movie man. Oh you have to look handsome the trailer looked great. It looked like a cowboy I will tell you that much. I was like this motherfucker came to fucking play Can I tell you a quick story about that actually? Fuckin' play. Can I tell you a quick story about that, actually? So we went to the premiere and we're looking and the studio kind of took over that movie and they made it even worse than it already was.
And it wasn't that bad. It really wasn't that bad. But we left early, as one does, at their own premiere. And there was a guy in a wheelchair that left just before me that didn't see that I left behind him when my wife and I left the door and he thought he was by himself and he was wheeling himself out
and he said 86 minutes of a waste of fucking life. Ah! Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha The worst review I've ever gotten. I'd rather lose the other leg than see that shit again. Yeah, exactly, exactly. It's really funny. Sorry to interrupt. Well, I don't wanna. Yeah, go ahead, Charlie. I don't wanna rant on your parade,
but just let me know if it's now or 40 minutes I can talk about Dune, because I have 800,000 questions. Okay, you can talk about Dune anytime you want. You can start now. If you want, I was gonna start a little further back than his most recent project to be seeing on. Josh, so I wanted to talk, man, it's so great to have you.
You're one of the all-time great dudes. And I really mean that just outside of even the shit that we do, you're a great dude. And you started, obviously, your dad was in the business, your mom was in the business. And so you started with that, and yet you kind of took you a minute. You didn't start, you weren't like a child actor
in the sense that, like when you were first young, you weren't really doing it. Am I right about that? You were kind of outside of LA, and then you kind of came back to it? Is that sort of cool? Yeah, I wasn't, I was born in LA. I was born in Santa Monica,
which goes back five generations, I believe. Wow. St. John's. St. John's. Where my father was born and my grandfather was born. Holy shit. And my kid, my kid, two of my kids were born in St. John's. Wow. So, no, I was raised, we left the valley.
I believe it was Chatsworth when I was five and we went to Passerobels. My mom was in the business as an assistant casting director, but that was it. Primarily she ran a wildlife way station and took wild animals away from people who had illegally taken them out of the wild and had them jailed.
My mother was a five foot three Texan blonde tornado. I smell a real compelling one hour episodic. Right? Yeah. And by the way, we just wrote a book that's gonna be out in November 19th that I didn't really know what the book was and it's kind of an unconventional memoir
but it's very mother heavy. Fucking eight. Where you wrote? What's the name of it? Plug It. It's not, I can't plug it. Because I'm not allowed to, but yeah. But it is coming out in November, Harper Collins. But yeah, man, so my dad was an actor.
He stayed in LA most of the time. He went back and forth and drove the four hours to Paso Robles. So I had no real, I mean, I think I went on his sets. I think I went on Marcus Welby once and I think I went on Amityville horror once. And I was up on the catwalk at 11 years old where he walked in. And I didn't know, I didn't know the process. We never talked about it.
So Tracy, the catwalk is the permanent walkways way up at the top of the soundstage, usually like 30 feet above the ground. Way up at the top, so I'm looking down and I'm watching my dad, you hear action, which I don't even know what that is, and he comes in through the door with an ax and goes to another door. That's crazy.
Where somebody's doing off camera to help him out, but I don't know that. No, no! And he's axing the door. And I'm like, and it reminded me of this story that I heard once of Laura Dern saying the first time she ever saw her dad on film was his head rolling down a flight of stairs.
Oh my God. But I remember that there was no, there was never anything, I don't have that story of like, oh my God, when I was four, I was doing little plays I made up on my head in front of my family and I just knew at five, this is, yeah, it was none of that. So I had no interest in the acting thing and then ultimately just to jump forward,
I took, I was kind of flunking out of school once we moved to Santa Barbara and I did an improv class. And I didn't even know what it was. It was like, you can do underwater basket weaving or improv. And I was like, I guess I'll do the improv. But really had like a bad taste about the acting thing because my dad made money and then spent that money. And then we had no money. And then we had money. And then we had no money. And I said, what the fuck would anybody wanna do that? So ultimately I took that class
and I remember I was the first person asked to get up and she said, so what this is is you create a character and any character you want, any character that comes to mind and from the house, the students, we're gonna ask you questions and you answer as that character. And I had created some kind of middle-aged New Yorker and I don't even know how I knew that at that point. Like an overweight middle-aged balding New Yorker.
And- How old were you? I think I was at that point maybe 15, 14, 15. And then when I was answered, then there was laughter, right? And that was it. Like that was so- You loved that. Yeah, so it had nothing to do with what I was answered, then there was laughter, right? And that was it. Like that was so, yeah. So it had nothing to do with what I was surrounded by. If anything, I was never gonna be an actor.
And it was that kind of drug induced, the drug of the laughter. Yeah, yeah, for sure. Well that or the attention or the, you can see that you're good at something. Like I wonder, because I think for any kid, yeah, but any kid right at that age, if you put something in front of them
that they don't suck at and they get some sort of, you know, charming sort of social status, I mean, I'm seeing it with my kids now, Willie, I'm sure you are too, you know, it's like right about this age, then we're between 12 and 17, like you're trying to like, where do I fit in? What's my lane?
What's my group? What am I good at? What should I never do again? And for me, it was the same thing, Josh. It was sort of this, this acting like, well, that's where I got my attention. That's where guys thought I was cool and girls wanted to hang out with me. And it could have been anything else. I did this play. I did 12th night, Shakespeare's 12th night in high school. I didn't understand a word I was saying. And until there was an audience, there's one line that says, I'll make one too.
And that's the end of the scene. And it got a massive laugh. 16, 17 years old, no idea why anybody laughed. And I was like, oh, that's who that character is. And that's why people are laughing. And then it clicked. So yeah, it's interesting, Jason, what you just said. It's like, until you get that drug,
you just don't know what it is. I was just thinking about like, how strange you do something and then people give you a lot of positive feedback and why would you wanna do that? Right, you gotta be careful what you put in front of your kid at that age, cause that's what they're gonna end up doing. But Josh, when you did, like, Amityville horror was damaging to me.
Like, I saw that as a kid. And I was like, it was like, it was one of the scariest things I've ever seen. You growing up on that set, did you, could you then go back and watch the movie having experienced seeing filming it and get immersed into it? Or did you see the, how the sausage was made?
But not having grown up on the set, only having seen that scene. But even that, even that. No, I had no interest, man. I'm telling you, I had no interest and it wasn't until very irresponsibly, my dad took me to the theater, the mission theater, to see apocalypse now.
Sure, yeah. Yeah, yeah. Which, I mean, that was one of those, that's one of those immersive things where you're like What the fuck are they doing? How old were you when you saw that? I was 11 Yeah, that's enough. I was two and a half Sorry, sorry. Yeah, you were Hollywood two and a half fucking seeing that 11 like I don't think I saw Well, what about Jaws? I mean, Jaws was out in, what, 7-5?
Jaws? I saw Jaws in the theater. I was six. I was six at 7-5, and that's why. Or Rocky, do you remember seeing Rocky? Oh, yes. And like, the fact that like he doesn't win the fight, but it's a great, big, happy ending,
I was just like, how do you pull that magic trick off? Yeah, exactly. We'll be right back. Smartlist gets support from ZipRecruiter. Tis the month of St. Patty's Day. And here's a random related fact. Did you know that the odds of finding a lucky four-leaf clover are one in 10,000?
I'd say that's pretty difficult. Fortunately, if you're a business owner or hiring manager, you don't need luck to find top talent for your team. You need ZipRecruiter. And right now, you can try it for free at ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. Zip Recruiter's powerful matching technology shows you qualified matches right after you post your job. Once you review your list of qualified candidates, you can easily invite them to apply. Aren't you just a wee bit curious to see how Zip Recruiter can help you? Well, today's your lucky day because you can try ZipRecruiter for free!
Just go to ZipRecruiter.com slash SmartLess. In fact, four out of five employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. Once again, just go to this exclusive web address to try ZipRecruiter for free. That's ZipRecruiter.com slash SmartLess. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. This episode of SmartLess is brought to you in part by Skinny Pop Popcorn. Looking for some excitement?
Check out Skinny Pop's new cheddar jalapeno popcorn. Made with real cheddar cheese and a pop of jalapeno, this new flavor is sure to spice up your daily snacking routine. For me, guess what I do? When I have a sandwich, whether it's a tuna sandwich or a peanut butter sandwich or whatever, instead of chips, sometimes I'll use Skinny Pop and I'll use that as my side. And guess what? It's delicious.
It is. It's a deliciously simple combination of popcorn, oil, and salt. Every bite of their perfectly popped original popcorn leaves you wanting more. Skinny Pop is light and tasty and perfect for any occasion, whether you're on the go, saving off boredom, or unwinding after a long day. In addition to the original popcorn, Skinny Pop offers a variety of delicious flavors, ranging from white cheddar to sweet and salty kettle, all perfectly popped endlessly delicious. Shop Skinny Pop now!
Thanks to Grammarly for their support. You know, I'm always writing emails, I'm actually writing post-its around my house, and I kind of just write, like, whether it's on the computer or handwrite, as fast as I can, and my brain always thinks faster than my hand, so I'm always getting the words wrong.
But no matter what kind of work you do, how you communicate is key. All those emails, reports, and presentations are equally important to the collaboration needed to get things done, and Grammarly can help. Grammarly makes me feel more confident in my writing, and it makes me more efficient in the fact that I can say so much with the fewest words. And it also just checks for my mistakes because I'm not in school anymore, I don't have a teacher to do it. You know what I mean?
96% of Grammarly users report that Grammarly helps them craft more impactful writing. By understanding your writing and context, Grammarly provides personalized suggestions to help you navigate even the most difficult work conversations. With 14 years of experience and just about every IT certification under the sun, Grammarly is the gold standard of responsible AI. Make a bigger impact at work with Grammarly. Sign up and download for free at grammarly.com slash smartlist. All right, back to the show. So, Josh, so then what happens and you were like, first of all, I don't wanna, it's kind of two questions.
When you were up there, you were kind of, you surfed a lot that played a big part in your life, right? You were a big time surfer, that took a lot of your time. You had a whole gang of pals who you surfed with. And then you kind of, and then you get goonies. And what's that like? How did that come about?
Cause that was your first thing really, right? Everything is super morbid. If I, every story, thank God for you guys. Being able to check. Welcome to the party. By the way, morbid podcasts are like the best. They do the best on the charts. Order a man.
We got Josh Brolin. Oh, what the fuck? Yeah, what the fuck? Um, yeah, what? So I grew up with these guys called themselves, we called ourselves, I'll include myself in that, the Cito rats. And most of those guys, 37 out of probably 50 of us are dead now.
And that was the beginning of the punk rock era. That was an amazing time. It was an electric time. It was an electric time. It was a fun time. But I got kicked out of my house at 16. And I went down to, I lived on my dad's couch. Wait, what was your fence? I had the fences my mouth, you know?
I just grabbed myself in a lot of drawers. Cast me a few schools. Words, yeah, exactly. So, yeah, my mom said, it's time for you to leave. And I left and I stayed with my dad who was living with his girlfriend in this apartment. And this was an attempt to kind of get my shit together. So I made up a resume.
I started doing martial arts, which one does when you try to get your shit together? Sure. And I was fairly decent at that. And I started competing martial arts, which one does when you try to get your shit together? Sure. And I was fairly decent at that. And I started competing doing that. And at the same time I made up, my dad said, why don't you like try and like work a little bit?
Why don't you do theater? Why don't you do that? And I was like, oh yeah, I can do that. And I made up a resume. It was 100% made up. And I went from agent to agent trying to get an agent and saying that I was at, like I had done streetcar at the Liberaro International Theater.
There is no Liberaro International Theater. Sure, sure. And at the same time I did see streetcar and I saw East of Eden and those two movies had a major impact. Anyway, somebody, Hillary Shore, took me on, even though she knew the whole resume was bullshit. And she took me on.
And I probably had back then, when you would do auditions, you would go to three or four auditions in a day. Yeah, yeah. And I think I did around 350 auditions before I met Dick Donner and Steven Spielberg. Wow. I didn't really know who they were, but that was a six audition process before they said.
Really? With nothing but a fucking Thomas guide and a lot of hope, right? Bunch of headshots, yeah. It's an accident. Yeah. And I wasn't good. I can't say I was good.
I said, the same goes to today. If you do Dune with a certain director, it's gonna be a certain thing. Somebody who understands what take to use, whatever. And then if you do Dune with a certain director, it's gonna be a certain thing. Somebody who understands what take to use, whatever. And then if you do Dune with Denis Villeneuve, it's gonna, you know, the foundation, the worst it's gonna be is still really good. Well, so actually, talk about that.
And now we're gonna end it Dune, Sean. But I do wanna say, as a sort of entree to that, that's a really interesting point, Josh, that you can go and do something. And part of the reason that people like you choose directors and choose projects are because you say, I wanna be with that person because I believe that I'm in good hands.
I believe that A, that the script's good. I believe that their vision of it executing is good and that the way that they're from start to finish, from casting to shooting to editing to all of that kind of stuff, that they're from start to finish, from casting to shooting to editing to all of that kind of stuff, that they're gonna do something that I believe, that I trust in, right? Like, because you're putting your trust in that process.
Yeah, but I also think, you know, just to kind of preface it, and then more up your alley, Sean, is that, you know, theater, I met a guy named Anthony Zerbe, and Anthony Zerbe was one of the great Shakespearean actors, maybe the lesser known, and he had a poetry thing that he did,
which I can't think of anything more, I don't know if you remember Cafe Lalo, back in the day on Fairfax, and Steve Baldwin would go and read his poetry, and it was all just super dumb. And I met a guy around that time named Anthony Zerbe. And Anthony Zerbe and Roscoe Lee Brown, the great Roscoe Lee Brown would do
an hour and a half of poetry. And I saw it and it fucking blew my mind. The fact that they had such a command over the language and they understood pause, they understood cadence, they understood weight, and all that kind of stuff. So I got together with Anthony, and I started doing theater in Rochester, New York,
and I did five seasons of theater in Rochester, New York. So when you get that kind of vibe, what you were talking about back from the audience, and when a play is not very good, and yet chemistry is really good with another actor, and then that can kind of send the play in a different place and you see people crying and you see people laughing. You know, again, that's the addiction.
You're like, oh, there's response here and there's, you know, there's kind of- I can move you. Yeah. Do you have a favorite of those plays back when you- I did a play that never went anywhere called Pits and Joe and it was a guy with traumatic brain stem injury that had gotten into a motorcycle accident
and was based in truth. And this woman wrote it about her and her brother. And I did one of those things where, back when you wanted to be Daniel Day-Lewis or whoever, and I went into the care center that Joe was at. And I checked in, I met with the head of the care center, I met with like the five heads, the psychology head and all that.
And I said, I really wanna live in here as one of these people for a couple of weeks. Can you not tell anybody else that I'm actually not, I'm gonna see if I can pull it off. And I remember that like after the second day there was somebody I was smoking or something or trying to smoke or put a cigarette in my mouth. And a nurse came up to me and she said,
Josh, you can't, you're not a lot. And she was screaming in my ear. And I wanted to say, shut the fuck up. She's like, I'm acting, okay? I'm acting. Ah. She bought a ticket to the opening night, yeah. There was the head of the psychology that there,
he hated me and he hated what I was doing. And I was waiting by myself to have my, you know, two cigarettes of the day. And he walked by me and it was just he and I. And he whispered, or he kind of like, you know, two cigarettes of the day. And he walked by me and it was just he and I. And he whispered, or he kind of like, you know, snarky, said as he was walking by, he said, Joe would never do that. Remember, I felt a rage. And it was the rage that I felt.
And then the connection between if Joe feels a rage, he would never be able to get up. So therefore I can't get up. And that was what I needed to go play that. I love that. I love that. I love that. I have you stayed that kind of a researching actor, or have you found that, you know, what you've got, what you've absorbed in your life gives you enough of a toolbox to apply to any character that you're attracted to nowadays? I think both, and I think what I'm going through right now,
you know, I've been very lucky to be offered a lot of really nice things recently. And I think that the hunger right now is to kind of go back to 2008 or 2000, or go back to that theater experience because I miss having to do or feeling like I have to do the research. Well, I tell you something about the research.
It reminded me, Josh, of a story you told me years ago where you, when you did No Country for Old Man, which is just such a spectacular movie. One of my favorites. Oh my God. So, so good, and you're so good at it. And I remember we were talking, maybe it was when we were doing Jonah Hex,
but you were saying there's that scene early on where you're going to, and the motorcycle accident reminded me of this, where you got to shoot the guy and you take your boot off to level the gun. Is that, am I remembering that correctly? Yeah, because I had gotten to it. Yeah, yeah, yeah, I had gotten to a motorcycle accident.
And you didn't tell them, tell these guys what happened. No, two days after I got, so I was doing this small movie with Brittany Murphy, and I was having to go from, I had gotten no country, and there was no way I was gonna get no country. I even read for no country, and their only response because I was doing a movie at the time we sent in the video
and their only response was who lit it. So they didn't even comment on my act. I totally just thought it was eerily well lit. And then I got in there as the last reading and I got that part, you know, they asked me that afternoon, would you be interested in playing this part? I was like, well, hold on, let me think about it. And then I got into a motorcycle accident two days later,
going from one wardrobe fitting to the other and I snapped my collarbone in half. And I called them and I said, and I had prepped the doctor. I said, look, Ethan wants to talk to the doctor to find out how bad it really is. And I told the doctor, you need to tell them that's a hairline fracture. I tried to become as intimidating
as I could possibly become. I was like, you're not going to be a doctor anymore if you don't say these words in this way. And it turned out that the only reason I was able to do the role was because Lou Ellen gets shot in the right shoulder had it been the chef left shoulder I couldn't have done it. So he gets so we're in the beginning of the movie, he puts the, he's supposed to be standing up
and shooting at the antelope. And I couldn't do it. I couldn't lift up the, because literally it had only been two weeks since I snapped my collarbone and I was letting it heal naturally. So I called somebody and there was somebody who knew a sniper in Vietnam and how could I hold the gun?
I love that you called somebody who knew a sniper. Sure and how could I hold the gun? I love that you called somebody who knew a sniper. Sure. Yeah. I tend to know those people. Yeah. So yeah, so that's why the boot is, I took my boot up and- And the Cone Brothers seem to like that as sort of a character choice
that you would use the boot or was a boot off camera? No, you see it. No, the boot's on camera. And they liked that just because it was viable. He takes his fucking boot off. Yeah. And then he balances the gun on his fucking boot because he literally can't hold the gun.
Yeah, by hand. While we're there, before we get to Sean's Dune Fiesta, anything about, the Coen brothers are just, you know, like every other person in this industry, they are my North Star and and they can do no wrong. I just, to work with them, I'm just so like, I'll take anything you can give me about what that experience is like.
It's funny, cause I've tried to make it in the past and you're on talk shows and you're like, tell me about the Cohen's, tell me a funny story. And there's so fucking normal. The greatest thing that I have done three movies in a short with the Coens. And the greatest thing I ever got from them was after every scene I've ever done,
especially in the beginning, with the exception of one story that I'll tell you, I've never ever gotten a great scene. I've never gotten a thumbs up. Great job, right. Really, just the moving on is the confirmation. It's literally moving on and looking up and seeing their backs walking away to the next set.
No way, wow. So at best, it's like, hey, what'd you think? Like maybe later on, I'd go, you know, what'd you think of that scene? And they go, man. Yeah. Like basically it's got, it's, we got what we need. Right.
And you did your job correctly. Which is why we hired you. That was my dad's reaction growing up. That was your dad? Yeah. There's a trauma in that. Oh shit, he didn't have it. How would you, how would you know what his reaction was?
Yeah. Unless you could read his mind through the rear view mirror, you know. You could read people's minds from 50 miles away. Woody Harrelson was the only guy who couldn't remember his lines during No Country, and we had that scene in the hospital together, and he talks the majority of the time. And he couldn't get through his fucking lines.
And then when finally he did one take, where he kind of stumbled through his lines, and then I saw the Coens come from behind set and they looked up and they go, wow, that was amazing. And I was like, you gotta be fucking kidding me. It's just literally stuttering through his shit. You're holding his cue cards, right? Nothing, nothing.
They were just happy they got a take. Let's be honest, so formal. Wait, so Dune, so first of all. Here we go. Okay, so wait, so arrive. So, is the sand real? Let's just start. So, okay, I'm so bored.
Can I talk about Dune? I can't stand in your eyes to say that. No, by the way, is it real? Is it a real place? Is it a real place? Yes. No, it's one of, no country real place? Is it a real place? Yes. No Country for Old Men is one of my favorite movies too. But Dune, I can't get, first of all,
Arrival is one of my favorite movies as well. Yeah, me too. Me too. So clever and well made, and the script is amazing. You're the best director. Tell Tracy why that's connected, John. Oh, because he directed,
the same director, director of Arrival is. Danny Vilna, right. And so, yeah. And so, D. Oh, cause he directed the same director, director to rival as Danny Veldum. Danny Veldum, right. And so, yeah. And so, so Dune, I kind of- You also directed Sicario, by the way. Yeah, and you were also great in that. Maybe we're top three. I want to get in, we'll after Dune,
I want to get in Sicario. Okay, so wait, so I want to know, just like Jason said, it was like the Ethan's, what's it like on that set? Where are, I mean, are they sets? Are you really in the desert? Like how much of it is it real? How much of it isn't?
Most of it is practical. Most of it is. That's just, just let me just pause the interview right here. Well, cause it looks like it's really in the desert. It does, doesn't it? Jason, please go on. What part gave you that impression? Was it the desert?
Would they be spending less money if they just green screened the whole goddamn thing? Or that maybe be a little bit more? It's actually really sweet because he's like, Oh, I'm blessed. Full fan boy right now. I'm massive, massive fan. Ask him to stand up.
You can see his pants are off. And you're so good at this. And then have him pan his camera right and you'll see Scotty just in full pole mode. Go ahead. Next question, Sean. Go ahead and finish Scotty off with the next one. Wait, so isn't it, by the way, isn't it wild that you guys had to hold the release because of the strike?
Speaking of holding the release. So now it's coming in March, is that what it is? Yeah, was that why? Yeah, and then we went back for reshoots in the first one during the pandemic, which we hadn't, we did it before the pandemic. What is it? Tell me what it's like working with him.
And is it the opposite of the Ethan's of the Coens? I mean, he's. Well, he's also Canadian, is he not, Denny? He is Canadian, he's French Canadian. Right, so he's incredibly kind and probably effusive. Thank you. With his compliments. Thank you. Right? He's coming up giving you a little high five
at the end of a good take. He is actually. Yes. Yeah, but what I was going to say about the Cohen's thing is that taught me a great thing and I don't really look for that anymore. I don't. But I mean, what he's accomplished in you two in Dune
is like it's hard to get the tone and the feel and the actors and the script and the sets and just everything works perfectly. It creates a world that we haven't seen. It's very collaborative, you know, and if I can go back to Sicario for a second, you know, I had turned down because he wasn't really an established director
at that point. He had done us on D. He had done one American film with Hugh Jackman. What was that film called? Not passengers, not visitors. You know what I'm saying? Yeah. About the kidnap.
And Jake Gyllenhaal, which was actually really good. But I said, I don't know why, because I think it was a really small part anyway, to get through this. Was Bob Elswit on board yet? I mean, I think that wasn't even in the TV. You mean Deacons. Oh, was it Deacons it did? It was Deacons.
And I had worked with Deacons a couple of times and it was also Benicio and it was Emily Blunt. And anyway, I said no. I said no twice. And I don't know why, but and he called me and he said what every director says and lies about, which is we're going to expand this role. Right.
Like what it is right now is not really what it's going to be. And you're like, we're full of shit, because I've heard that from everybody. But the truth is, and whether it was just kind of happened this way because of fate or whatever, it was so expanded. And it was so once we got on set, it was like such a vibe that all came from him, which was, this isn't working, so let we got on set it was like such a vibe that that all came from him
Which was this isn't working so let's work on this or I'm gonna knock on your trailer door Benicio doesn't want to talk anymore He thinks you should talk because you like to talk and I'm like I'm a different fucking character But we need this exposition. How can we make it behavioral so on and so forth? So it became a very very collaborative process. So that's what I get, you know, Denis is my good friend now, but he's a guy who I would work on anything with because that kind of collaborative effort to me is the top.
But Sean points out like Sicario, you know, is about a world that exists, right? Like this, it's a reflection of this real world, maybe height, maybe not, I don't really know, but like of this thing, things like Dune, as? Like this, it's a reflection of this real world. Maybe height, maybe not, I don't really know, but like of this thing, things like Dune, as Sean pointed out, it's world building, right? It's creating a world.
It's creating a whole thing. That's so hard to get right. Yeah, no kidding. Yeah, but there was a guy at Zev Boroh, I know from New York, and he's my good buddy, and he read through that whole series three times when he was a kid. So he knows it as well as anybody, as well as Deni does, you know three times when he was a kid, so he knows it as well as anybody,
as well as Denis does, you know? And when he saw the movie, I kinda snuck him in in Santa Fe when I saw the first one, and there was a pause after the movie ended, and this guy's a 48-year-old guy, and he stood up and he started screaming, yes, that's it, yes, fuck yes! That's great, That's great. What do they call him?
What are they, his nickname, Zeb the Virgin, right? I mean, he went through all three. He's 40. Zeb the Virgin. Wait, now that you're, now that you've had all the success and you've been working for so many years and you told us the story about how, you know, your dad had money, then didn't have money,
had money, then didn't have money. And so kind of left you in a weird place, probably growing up. How are you with money now and handling it? Are you more responsible, and you would try to teach your kids about the responsibility of money? Yeah, it's an ongoing subject about where we live
and what that promotes, and what that, you know, given that I grew up on a ranch, given that we have a ranch that's three miles away from the ranch I grew up on, ranch, given that we have a ranch that's three miles away from the ranch, I grew up on, but I take my kids there a lot, I take my kids right now. They haven't been to the set very much, but I take them wherever we shoot.
I have a 30 year old, a 35 year old, a three year old, and a five year old. That's crazy. Wow. So. Now what kind of grandfather skills does he have? What kind of grandma skills does Babs have? I mean, what do these family get-togethers like?
You know, there's a real, for lack of a better word, hard on for my kids, my young kids, with said grandparents. Yeah, and really quick, just for my sister, and I'm just saying this for my sister, Josh. Yeah, no you're not. Your dad is James Brolin who's married to Barbara Streisand. No, really?
Yeah, yeah, no, you should call him. Yeah, it's amazing. That's it. Go dad. It's for my sister and for my sister, Tracy. But they're keyed in on these two. Was it different than the first two kids? Like they got another crack at it.
I think in my first two kids, definitely, they laugh at it now where they were like, we're still here, by the way. But the young kids are very cute. And I think that they're at an age now where things have slowed down enough where you start to appreciate those Familiy etc etc, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, that's great What would you say is the biggest difference between your fathering on the first two versus the the second two?
What would have you yeah? You've got a little little lighter blend on the on blend on your hydration this round. I mean, that's just the fucking truth, man. I mean, I was in and out and that kind of thing, but you know, I mean, I think it's okay to say this. Even though it's an anonymous program, my son's sober, my daughter's married to a sober dude. That's great. My wife's sober. I love that.
I love that. Right. So they learned a lot from your mistakes or your... Hopefully, in all honesty, you know what I mean? I think we were all pretty open. I tried not to let the thing cross over and it did cross over a few times and we talk about it, but it's a very open dialogue with us. When you mentioned about you getting kicked out
at 16 years old because of your mouth and stuff, do you recognize the signs and any of your kids that they kind of might repeat the same behavior that you did when you were born? No, because I think mine was so extreme that it was definitely a warning light as opposed to let me try and emulate that to see if I can pull that off. Uh-huh, right, right. We'll be right back. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp.
You know, everybody, including myself, is always like, God, there's not enough hours in the day. I have so much to do. I can't find even five minutes. But I think if we're being honest with ourselves, we can probably find an hour, right? If you're really willing to do that, you can probably find an hour for yourself. The question is for everyone, time for what? Right? If time was unlimited, how would you use it? How would you decide what's
important enough to make time for? So therapy can help you find what matters to you so you can do more of it. So if you, when talking to a therapist, you discover, you know what, I always want to, I wish I was riding bikes more, like actually out on the street. That's one of my things. I'm like, if I had a bike, I would actually ride it. Anyway, I'm rambling. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule.
Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Learn to make time for what makes you happy with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlist today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash smartlist. Smartlist is brought to you in part by Rakuten. Think of the last time you bought something to wear.
Something to decorate your house, something for your family or friends. What if each time you made a purchase, you got a little something back with Rakuten? You can. You can earn cash back on just about anything you buy from over 750 stores. If you've ever bought electronics, home decor, fashion, beauty, or booked a trip, well, you could have gotten cash back. But do not worry, it's not too late. It's free and easy to use and you get cash back deposited in your PayPal account or sent to you as a check.
Earn cash back at stores like Sephora, Old Navy, and Expedia. It is the smartest way to shop, plain and simple. Start your shopping at racketon.ca or get the Racketon app. That's R-A-K-U-T-E-N. And now, back to the show. You know what's funny, Josh?
The other day I was reading this story in the Wall Street Journal. These guys don't know what that is, but there was a story about... Smart list. About weed. There was a story about weed and it was saying how they've seen an uptick in kids having psychotic breaks
as a result of cannabis as compared to 10, 20 years ago. So I send it to my ex. I text it to Amy like immediately and she goes, why are you sending me this? And our older sons are 13 and 15. And I go, because weed is very readily available, and there are things around, and I'm very nervous about it. Like I just had this, you know what I mean?
It wasn't like- But I understand, it was like, remember back in the 70s, I remember I was a friend of my dad's in Passerobles, and I was on the floor or something, and I looked under his bed, and I found a drawer, a pot, and I rolled it up in some writing paper, and tried to smoke it when I got home and I was like eight or nine.
But even if I was able to smoke it, the high would have been, you wouldn't have been that high. Right, you smoke a full joint nowadays, you gotta call your mom. One hit nowadays. Oh no, no, no, yeah, yeah, yeah. Before I got sober, I remember,
I loved the idea of dispensaries and I loved the idea behind the science and it all. And I was like, what does this do? And where did this and how do you make this? I made it for the science too. Yeah, I know, I get it. But there was a guy, he was from Poland and we kind of would go through this whole thing
and I would pretend like I didn't smoke because I didn't really love smoking very much. And then I would give it to my friends. But then one night, I was home alone and I was supposed to read this essay that my daughter had done. And I went outside and I was like, well, maybe I'll try it. I'll just try a little bit.
And I took a little hit and I got too much smoke. And then I coughed it out. And by the time I had exhaled, I was convinced that there were cross hairs from across the building on my head, and I was slowly lowering behind my... You know, army crawl back into the house? Yeah, and then I tried to read the essay, and I read the same first line about 125 times.
And that was one hit, man. So I get it. You needed to get into the edibles. It's heavy duty. Sean, Sean, I love it when Sean gets on. I love it. Well, Jason, his book is coming out and it's about edibles. But he's written the first line 120 times.
Sean, when Sean gets on weed, it is my fate. When you get on weed, who's old? But when Sean smokes weed or takes an edible, it's the funniest. It makes me laugh, Sean, anytime. Well, I get like tunneling. As he's getting to the hospital. And I get spurts of little energy.
But wait, like when I was a kid, I was so afraid of doing anything wrong. Like I was, I remember, I was scared about having a library book out too long. And I thought I was gonna get into massive trouble. Where does it come, where does that come from? Where you're like, yeah, I'll try this. I'll do this. I'll get in this trouble.
I'll beat the shit out of this kid. I'll smoke this stuff. Like what is that? I never beat the shit out of a kid. I was never that guy, you know? I bullies maybe, but I was never, even though we all fought a lot, but it was, that was the culture.
That was the culture that I grew up in in punk rock and all that kind of stuff. Back when parents were doing blow instead of parenting. Imagine what a bummer it would be to get into a fight with Brolin, it would fucking suck. At any age. At any age. I'll bet at eight he could really square you up. I went over there, I went over to Brolin, remember I came over to try your coal puns like five years ago and we got in the fucking coal puns and he's a couple years old With me. I was like look how fucking stacked this motherfucker Baby
Are you in better shape now than you've ever been in your life? I'll be I was I was in better shape during dune than I've been in in a very very long time I think I did when I did Deadpool 2, I think that's the best shape I've ever been in. Sean, cool it. I'm just saying, it's good looking. But you still do the martial arts and have you ever in or would you and can I promote you and Downey
fighting each other? I would do that. I was just with Downey and we were talking about you two days ago. I'm gonna fucking pop that up. Wait, can I get in on that, Arnett? Yeah, I'm getting it running down. Downey, Brolin Brolin fight. Well let's do it in, do we think Vegas Atlantic City or what about Laughlin? Laughlin would be kind of
kitschy right? Remember that wasn't there like an animated thing like celebrity fights or something like that? It was like a claymation thing. Yeah look it up afterwards. It was super fun. I'd like to make that a reality. Oh, that's right. There was a Claymation show. Yeah. I'm bored with the acting. I want to fuck celebrities out. There's that clip. I would fucking, I am backing you, Brolin. You're my fucking dog in this one. Wait, Josh, do you know Brendan Shanahan? He's a friend of Will's. He's a hockey player. He's a hockey player. Retired hockey player, president of the Toronto Maple Leafs, one of the all time great guys. So Will and Brendan and I were out to dinner.
This is a few weeks ago. And I said to Brendan Shanahan, who's been in, you know, a thousand fights on the ice rink. He holds the record for the most what they call Gordy Howe hat tricks, which is goal assistant fight in a game. Right. So I told him, I always had this a little tiny, tiny, tiny bit of a fantasy of getting in a fight
because I've never been in a fist fight, right? We'll see on the receiving end, right? Just getting beat to shit. Yeah, literally in hockey fights for you, just grab somebody. What if you pull my hair right before you? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, like that. You know, that's what it's like.
By the way, it's borderline fetish, but go ahead. No, no, just because I don't know. I would pardon me, just want to know what that feels like. And so Brendan, Brendan takes me out. I'm gonna make that happen. So Brendan takes me out and grabs me and he's teaching me how to fight. And in two, and I can't stop smiling because I think it's so funny.
And he goes, first of all, wipe that fucking smile off your face, because you're going to get into a fight. And how'd you feel? How'd you feel when he said that? You got scared? Made me laugh harder. Yeah, he's like, stop looking like you're going to enjoy this, god damn it.
So he grabs me in some crazy hold in two seconds flat. I can't move my entire body. And he's like, this is you would be dead. So you had just beat the shit out of your face. He had his arm wrapped around. And then I would just start filling you in like this. And he just's like, this is, you would be dead. So you'd just beat the shit out of your face. He had his arm wrapped around, and then I would just start filling you in like this. And he just starts going, Sean's laughing and he did say, by the way,
it's at the back entrance, that little back side door behind the polo lounge. There's nothing more elitist than that scenario. Lord, what about MMA kind of stuff? Are you training with that too? Like could you, is that your skill set or is it more martial arts? I think it was, martial arts no longer,
even though I nut, like the Gracie's, become good friends and through Laird Hamilton and all that and I have massive respect for them. But no, I think the getting in shape, MMA, Dana White's a really close friend of mine. I love MMA, I've always loved boxing. I didn't think MMA would last or UFC would last and it has and it's incredible and I get very into it.
Have a lot of guys come over to my house. We just built this extra kind of MMA barn. What time? You can watch MMA on what? What time? What time? What time? I'll invite you. You know what's funny, Josh is all this stuff You can watch MMA on what? What time? What time? What time?
I'll invite you. You know what's funny, Josh, is all this stuff, and you do a lot of this stuff, and you're very in shape and whatever, but over the last couple of years, I have noticed, and I think you mentioned going to listen to poetry years ago, but anybody who follows you on Instagram or anybody who gets texts from you,
talking about your day or the things that you're grateful for, i.e. gratitude lists, knows that you've kind of veered into that. As much of a guy you like to sort of mix it up, you've also become quite, and maybe this is just a result of older age and having younger kids again, you've become quite ponderous. You've become quite, you're really appreciating the world
around you in a way that's pretty astound. I know, I'm gonna make out with you now too. He's got that soft, chewy center. But it's true, man. You do, like every day you talk about, and you talk about things you really open about, appreciating your wife, loving your wife, loving your kids. You're really open about it. And I think there's something super, super, super nice
and vulnerable and beautiful about that. Thanks. I appreciate that very much. I don't think it's a new thing, but I think it's ramped up recently because I love the idea of contrast in the fact that I ride a vintage motorcycle or with a group of dudes or the fact that I'm perceived as this scrappy gnarly whatever, Ultraman, the last man in Hollywood.
Oh, that's right. But then what is the count? It should be noted that Josh is smiling when he says that. Yeah, he's smiling. That I love the idea of contrasting that with, because there is an incredible sensitivity and I do love my kids. I will be raising, I had my first kid when I was 20
and my youngest, I'll be 70 when she graduates high school. Wow, so cool. And I love it, man. I love it in the writing. What would be the contrasting thing that would surprise most people? Like what is the softest thing that you do on a regular basis?
Okay, here's a story. Here's a story, and I don't know if this is the best story to tell, but the story, when we went to Atlanta and during the pandemic, we kind of moved to Atlanta where my wife is from. And nothing against Atlanta, but when I got to Atlanta, I realized I was in Atlanta.
I didn't realize Atlanta was in Atlanta, so I couldn't stay. But I was sitting there in such a nice house and I'm looking out the window and I see this kind of barrel-chested, tattooed, huge, goateed, tattooed guy in the middle of my yard and he's kind of looking up at a tree.
And I go, who the fuck is that? And I open the door and I go, hey man, and he looks at me and he goes, hey. And I go, yeah, what the fuck are you doing in my yard? And he looks at me and there's a long pause and he goes, I'm your gardener. And I go, oh fuck, I'm so sorry. And I went down there and I started talking to him.
And within 15 minutes, and I'm not kidding, I'm not exaggerating, within 15 minutes, he and I are in a total embrace, tears falling down our cheeks. Wow. And it turns out that he's 24 years sober. He runs the biggest sober biker club that's an international biker club in the world.
That's amazing. He's one of my best friends now. I love that. So I love the idea of this cosmetic thing that you immediately judge and then underneath it is whatever we're doing. I love that. Well, the biggest compliment I can give you
is I've never met you before. This is the first time. And you're completely, I feel completely at ease with you. I feel like I've known you forever. You seem so open and just normal down to earth and honest. And please put me in a chokehold. I'm sorry, I didn't know. And can you please keep putting me in a chokehold?
Maybe the best time joke of all time. And I want to spoon with you. You seem like the guy that would be really cool to spoon. Are you in New York by the way? Are you in... Sean, are you in New York? I'm in Los Angeles. You're in Los Angeles. My wife saw your play. I did not, admittedly. But my wife saw your play, which I heard was... Oh, please tell her thank you. You were truly a revelation.
Oh, that's very nice. It was... Honestly, it was so. Oh, that's very nice. It was, honestly, it was so, no, I know, Sean, fuck off, fuck off, it was so good. It deserves to get mentioned whenever we talk about it. It was so, so very good. Oh, speaking of Josh, you got any horrible, tragic theater stories?
Something that just went horribly wrong? You know, no, man, but just theater, theater is such a, it's a funny thing, You know, no man, but just theater, theater is such a, it's a funny thing. You know, it's like, my experience of theater is like you fucking people in Hollywood. Right. You're such phonies, you're such vakes, you don't understand the real thing.
And then that person three days later, you'll see it in like an El Pollo local commercial. Oh right, exactly. Or like, I'm coming out in March for pilot season, you got an extra bag? Yeah, literally. I find it the most hypocritical society I've ever, you know what I mean?
And I love it, and I just wrote a play, and we're trying to get that play done in Ohio, and it's really good, but I'm reminded again and again how much I hate the theater community. I'm just kidding, I'm totally kidding. That's really good, but I'm reminded again and again how much I hate the theater community. I'm just kidding, I'm totally kidding. He's totally kidding. One of my favorite questions, and we'll let you go, is with all of the incredible set experience that you have
and all the incredible directors you've worked with, have you ever been tempted to take all of that, which you've cherry picked from them, and sit in the chair yourself and direct something? You know, it's funny you would bring this up and I'm curious why you would bring it up because I was gonna bring it up regardless of whether you brought it up or not
but I reached out to you when I directed an episode of Outer Range which is something that I did with Amazon. Yeah. And a very strange kind of Western contemporary Western. And, you know, it's something that I've always wanted to do. I've directed theater. I've never directed, I directed a short,
but I've never directed something that was substantial and with money. And I reached out to you and I said, You were just thinking about it at the time, weren't you? I was thinking about it at the time. And I reached out to you and I said, you know, do you have any advice for me? And which I thought was really interesting.
Like why would I reach out to you? So obviously my respect for you. Who do you think you've called? No, but I love that I reached out to you and you said a great thing. You were like, don't, focus on the day players. You said, don't forget about the day players. That was one bit of advice that you gave me,
but you were so sweet and so kind of you kind of. And Tracy, the day players are the actors that are doing the parts that are not the starring roles. Maybe one line, three lines. Yeah, sometimes they're cast right from the local city that you're shooting in. And there's an instinct sometimes for them to potentially overplay their scene because they're only in a couple of scenes and sometimes
there's a directing. Which can take you right out of a scene. Right, yeah. And so is it directing? Which was your point, I think. Right. So how did that go? Really, really well. And I have to say that directing, and I know a lot of probably actors feel like this, it wasn't an opportunity to finally do the thing that I wanted to do that no director wouldn't let me do. But it was more that the myriad interests
that I've had in my lifetime that I never really understood all made sense suddenly. It was like I can utilize everything I've ever been interested in, everything that I've wanted to randomly learn and didn't know why now makes perfect sense. When you're available to somebody in the way that they need you to be available,
which changes from actor to actor and staff members, whatever, DP or whatever, and say, how can I be most helpful as opposed to how can I make my mark and you know Use my power because now I finally have it right Exactly, you know you think about doing it again perhaps I think that's the I think out of that has come a real interest in finding foreign directors right now and finding projects like that and really focusing on on
Another echelon of great directors. And yes, I would like to think that I would further that. I think it would be dumb not to. I think the only reason why it wouldn't happen is out of fear. And I'm kind of at 55, I'm kind of done with the idea of fear. But I was gonna say, the thing that Jason says to a lot of people and he talks about experience on set
and you've been doing it a long time. You do have so much experience, and you do have such a point of view, and that's important as a director, obviously as we all know, and I'm surprised that it's not something that you're like actively doing more because you do have such a strong point of view.
And know how, an incredible experience and comfort on a set in order to lead, you know? But I think it's also the fact, and I think this has to do with raising kids, is you're not afraid to be wrong, because you understand that wrong doesn't really pertain. You just have to make a decision. And you have to allow other people
to be able to lean on you, and stand behind your decisions, and know that it's not gonna be perfect and know that you're gonna have to compensate and know that you may have to fix some things in editing and all that kind of stuff. I just think it's another, it's kind of like photography. It's one of those things that you know you'll never master
and I love the idea of having to pursue something that you'll never master. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I love that, I'm in. Dude, we can fucking talk to you forever, honestly. I love you guys, I love this time. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I love that. I'm in. That's cool. Dude, we can fucking talk to you forever, honestly. I love you guys. I just love you, dude. Yeah, yeah.
Thank you so much for saying yes and doing this with us. Yeah, thank you. It's been a long time coming. Thank you for having me. I'm a master fan. Thank you, Sean. You're one of the all-timers, JB. Fucking love you, miss you, dude.
Miss you guys too. Thank you very much for this time, honestly. Thank you, pal. It was nutritious. Have a great rest of the day. Thanks, brother. I miss you guys too. Thank you very much for this time, honestly. Thank you, pal. It was nutritious. Have a great rest of the day. Thanks, brother. We'll talk to you soon. Thank you.
See you, Josh. Bye, bye, bye. That is, that's a JB. That's a real JB. That's a capital J, capital B. Yeah, if somebody says, hey, show me the best JB you got. I'm wheeling him out.
Sure, sure. And then like they'll say, well, second, third, fourth, what else? Just a backup. We're gonna go lowercase. Yeah, we're gonna go lowercase like a more of a beta JB. Yeah, I was like, hey guys. Hey, there you are. What if somebody said show me a great BJ?
And you'd say how much time you got? I'd say, Sean, let me look at your browser history. Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Oh God, yeah, super fun. Yeah, I had the pleasure back in the day, day when it was a different time, but it was still super fun hanging with him. And he's just- Yeah, he's one of those guys that's just electric. He is electric. He's really funny and he's really smart and he's interesting and all that stuff.
He's well read. Like he's just like one of those. But, Bateman, you've kind of known him, right? On and off for years? Yeah, a little bit. We, we shared an agent for a little while and, Oh right. Yeah. But, um, I think you, you know, I'm a lot better. I wish I, I wish I knew him, um, a lot better. I, I can hang on. We have a lot of friends in common, if you know what I mean. And, uh, he's just a fucking is he back here in LA now full-time? Yeah. They, he was here and then they moved to it.
Like he said, they moved to Atlanta for a bit and then they came back and. Oh, by the way, everybody in Atlanta, I love Atlanta. All right? Me too. It's, oh, it'll surprise you at your time. He does too. He was playing it up.
He does too. And his wife is from Atlanta, her whole family and his sister-in-law and brother-in-law who's a good friend of mine, Jackson, who we didn't talk about. He was a really good friend of mine, Jackson, who we didn't talk about, who's a really good buddy of mine who lives in Atlanta. Atlanta is a great, great town. You and I both had awesome experiences in that town.
Yeah, I shot a movie there. It was super hot, but it was wonderful. The people are awesome. It's a great town, et cetera. But that old, yeah, that JB is... I like what he said too, when he was like, he was talking about how he likes to, what does he say, like... Cont about how he likes to, what did he say?
Like... Contrast? Yeah, contrast. Contrast. Almost like bifurcate, right? Like what he's... How did you... Why didn't you use the bifurcate?
You just had... Oh, you had it. How he likes to... Go back. We're still rolling. We're still rolling? I think that's the... You like the way he likes to what?
Bye! Bye! Bye! Oh, Sean, great one. Stupid ass, get over here. I can't believe you blew it. Smart. What? Smart. What?
SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart guys. Hi guys. Oh Darcy's here. Guys, we have a friend with us today. Yes, oh my gosh. It's Darcy Cardin. Darcy.
Hello brothers. Hello sister. Hi. How are you Darcy Cardin? Good to see you guys. Thanks for having me. Darcy, who everybody knows from a million things, like the good place, and you were just on Broadway,
we're just on Broadway at the same time. With you, my Broadway brother. Yes. At the exact same time. Well Darcy, what we apologize to him is the same time. With you, my Broadway brother. Yes. At the exact same time. Well, Darcy, what we apologize to was you on Broadway. Don't you dare apologize. I was in a, no, don't apologize, I'm telling you not to. It was a limited run.
It was a short one. It was called the Thanksgiving Play. The Thanksgiving Play. And you, and I heard you were fantastic. Did you have to, I'm just having visions of you having to go through a full Thanksgiving meal every performance. Was that what it was? No, that's what I thought it was going to be before I read it to you. And I was like, God, eating on stage, what will that be like?
There's no Thanksgiving meal. I love that I go right to the eating. But we did, it was a bloody show. Yeah. Oh no. Which is kind of, which is killing turkeys. I don't want to give anything away, although I did just We were just killing turkeys. I don't wanna give anything away, although I did just say it was a bloody show.
And plus it's not running anymore, but it's a beautiful, wonderful, funny play written by Larissa Fasthorse, the first Native American woman to ever have a play on Broadway. Wow, that's cool. But we were truly covered in blood, head to toe every night,
so we had to like, we'd walk off stage and like get in the shower. Now I'm getting it, now I'm getting it. Not together. Now I'm understanding it. Now I'm getting the, now I'm understanding. Who said that? Storyline. No, nobody did. But Darcy, we're so excited because Smart List Media,
it has a new show and it's called Wiki Hole. That's right. No blood in it at all, right? No blood, we haven't had any blood yet. No blood yet. It's bloodless. But Wiki Hole premieres Monday, March 4th, wherever you get your podcasts.
So we're super excited. Tell our listeners that don't know as much about it as we do a little about what the WikiHole, what's in store for people in the whole. They need to know. They need to know. It's a super fun trivia show. We have a panel of three guests every time.
Different guests each week? Different, super funny, the funniest people you know. You're like the best, best, best, funniest actors and comedians and musicians. Some of my best friends, some of my future best friends. It's all, really, we've had like amazing people on it. And you basically, you have like one subject, one person? We start off with any random subject that you could look up on Wikipedia. Right, one person. We start off with any random subject
that you could look up on Wikipedia. Right, a donut. A donut, for example. It's like an improv class. Give me one word from the audience. Yes, totally, totally. And from there. You just, whatever you,
if you looked up donut on Wikipedia, you would find yourself clicking on something. Picture of me. Picture of Sean. Picture of Sean. So there's like little, what do they call, hot links inside? spicy hot links inside a wiki page. Delicious.
And when you click on those things, it'll take you down another sort of fork in the road and the history of donuts. We may get eventually to a picture of Sean because he's famous for his enjoyment of the donut. Live for Don. And then we'd get into a wiki hole that we'd get into Will and Grace. Yes. And into parental neglect.
All of those things. Yeah, okay. That's it, that's exactly right, yeah. And then it'll get back into SmartList and then it'll get back into wiki hole and you'll be right back where you started. Will, Will, Will, I don't wanna give anything away. I really don't.
And you're our tour guide throughout it. Yeah, I'm always gonna take you through the hole. I've listened to it and anything away. I really don't. And you're our tour guide throughout it. Yeah, I'm always going to take you through the whole. I've listened to it and it's fantastic. Thanks, Sean. I have hysterical. Love it. Thanks. I want to play wiki hole.
How do we, I want to play. Yeah, I would love to. Will you? Yeah, let's do it. Okay, so if we were to start with the smart list hole, there's so many, I could start with anything. You guys have had these incredible careers. You've worked with everybody. You have won awards.
But the thing that I keep coming back to is one man's sandwich, Sean. You have a goddamn tuna fish sandwich for lunch every day, is that right? Almost every day. Okay, almost every day. That is psychotic. I had to find out more.
So I wick find out more. So I wickied tuna sandwiches. Is he gonna have one today actually? Really? Okay, I might do. And here is our first question, okay? The top of the hole today is gonna be tuna fish sandwich.
Okay, so for the first question, you each have a chance to list the ingredients, okay? And you're gonna get one point per ingredient. Don't freak out, Sean, don't freak out. I see you're freaking out. Well, it just can be, there's so many different ingredients you could put in. I know, okay, but listen, listen.
There are five ingredients listed to make a tuna fish sandwich at the top of the tuna fish sandwich, wiki page. So the five ingredients, the most common five ingredients. Manes. Okay. Celery. Yeah. Wow, nothing for celery? No, no, no, no, I'm not gonna tell you until you all do it. Mannees. Okay. Celery. Yeah. Wow.
Nothing for celery. No, no, no. I'm not going to tell you until you all do it. Oh, okay. Yeah. You each say five. Okay. Mannees and celery.
Mannees and celery. Some people put mustard in it. Some people put capers in it. Okay. And like hard boiled eggs. Okay. Can I go now? Yes, please.
Tuna fish. Well, of course. Tuna go now? Yes, please. Tuna fish. Well, fucking idiot. Well, of course you didn't. Yeah, guess what? That's one of them. No, you didn't say it. You didn't say it. Well, that's too bad.
So tuna fish. No, it's not understood. Have you ever played a game before? Well, you're not gonna make a tuna fish sandwich with a chicken? It's like, oh, I've obviously got a touchdown. I'm not gonna go get the touchdown. I've just assumed that I got a touchdown. So tuna fish, mayonnaise, bread. Don't get the touchdown. I obviously just assumed that. Touchdown.
So tuna fish, mayonnaise, bread, celery, and pepper. Okay. Will, you ready? Yeah. Okay. Tuna fish. Yeah. I mean, I'm not saying this or no, I'm just saying,
yeah, you said that. Yeah, no, fish. Yeah. I mean, I'm not saying this or no, I'm just saying yeah, you said that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay. Bread. Mm-hmm. Mayo. Mm-hmm. Celery.
Slower, Will. No, no, he's thinking. Onion. Green onion. Ew. Okay. It's personal preference and that's only four. What's your fifth? No, I think he said, wait, didn't you say?
I know it's five. I think he said five. You guys. No, I'm... Guess what? What? Will got all fucking five right. You're joking me.
I'm not kidding. So say it again. Tuna, mayo, celery, onion, bread. So onion is a required element. So I think it's a common, yeah. So hang on, hang on. Sorry, Darcy, I don't wanna cut you off because these guys are about to apologize to me.
Please. For a ritual. Jason's got something in his mouth right now, but I imagine when he finishes chewing that thing, he's gonna apologize for going, the fucking, the fucking, the fucking, the fucking. White onion or white onion or red onion? Well, it just says onion.
It doesn't. It just says onion. That's interesting, I gotta try it with onion. Yeah, I bet it'd be delicious. I mean, all your sandwiches sounded delicious, but Will got them all right, Jason got four points and Will, I'm sorry, Jason got four points and Sean got two points.
Yeah, Sean, you lose. Great, great, we have more. It's anybody's game. Four points and will sorry Jason got four points and Shawn got two points. Yeah It's anybody's game, right? So what's the spicy hot link we go to offer you know what you are a donut? Do you put in yours? Tuna. Uh-huh. Don't say tuna like that. Of course you have to put fucking tuna. Celery and tons of mayo. Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Okay, great, delicious. Dorsey, wait, if you think I'm playing again after I fucking smoke these guys. No, we're not done. We're not done. You've just entered the hole. You've just started. You have to travel down into the hole now
We have to scale down this gigantic hole and this is even a small hole for you guys, but usually it's a really big hole Click click a spicy link Credit I want to get some credit for the restraint you're getting exercising Incredible, okay, so here's our next question. You will each have a chance to answer this. The closest without going over wins. What percentage of canned tuna in the US is used for tuna sandwiches? Okay, I'm a first, I'm first. And I will say, what percentage of canned tuna
is used for tuna fish sandwich? I would say 90. Okay. Okay, that's my guess. Great. Well, cause he said 90, I'll say 90. Okay. Okay, that's my guess. Great. Well, cause he said 90, I'll say 95. Okay. Dumb.
Should've said 91. Dumb. I'm gonna say 40. Okay, okay. 40. Now, I was shocked by this, but the answer is 52%. So will you fucking got it again?
Wow. Jesus. Why is that? Cause I bet you some of tuna that's canned is also used for animals, for cats and dogs and shit like that. I didn't even think of that. I was, all I could think of was casserole. Yeah.
It's a fucking, by the way, you don't want to keep playing this game with me with these guys. No, no, no, I bet we do. Let's have third one. You're gonna fucking, you're gonna burst into flames. Let's have third one. You're gonna fucking burst into flames. Let's go. What's the next hot line? Okay, here we go.
Okay. Look how mad he is. We're, okay. Here we go. Americans consume one third of the total amount of canned tuna sold worldwide every year. And yet, the tuna sandwich is not in the top three most popular sandwiches in the U.S. You'll each have a chance to guess three. What are the most popular sandwiches in the US. You'll each have a chance to guess three. What are the most popular sandwiches,
the three most popular sandwiches in the US, one point per correct? Go ahead, Sean. Go ahead, Sean. Peanut butter and jelly. Sean, you should win this. Yeah, let's just eat it. Peanut butter and jelly.
Okay. Like a turkey, like a regular turkey family. No, you can't generalize, be specific. Like, you know, something with turkey. No. Commit. I would have got a touchdown. What are we doing?
Why are you on the answer? To walk all the way down there and cross that line. Just say touchdown. Okay, peanut butter, jelly, turkey. Turkey and what's another popular sandwich? You're asking? And roast beef, I don't know. Okay.
That's the question. Okay. I would say a hamburger. Okay, that's the question. Okay. I would say a hamburger. Okay. It's not a sandwich. I would say a grilled cheese. Oh, grilled cheese. And then I would say a club.
Okay, okay. Three more popular sandwiches in the US. That's right. Here he comes. I would say ham, some kind of ham, ham and cheese. Well, which is it, ham or ham and cheese? Yeah, let's come in. Ham and cheese.
Ham and cheese. I'll say ham and cheese. I will say peanut butter and jelly. And I will say egg salad. Okay, wow. This is a tough one, you guys. If you, I would have guessed peanut butter and jelly would have been top number one.
It doesn't even crack the top three. Wow. That's why I didn't guess it. Okay, good. Well, Jason, you got one, which is, I know, which is grilled cheese. Grilled cheese, grilled chicken sandwich, surprising, and turkey sandwich. So Sean, you got one as well.
Okay. No burger, no PB and J. I wonder if they're not qualifying burger as a sandwich. So Sean, you got one as well. Okay. No burger, no PB&J. I wonder if they're not qualifying burger as a sandwich. I wonder the same. That's a big debate. Yeah, it is a big debate. They're not. I mean, this isn't the 1940s we go, I'll have a hamburger sandwich.
I'll just have a hamburger sandwich and a cup of coffee. Yeah, exactly. I don't like that. Put me through to Murray Hill 234. Yeah, exactly. I don't like that. And keep your sales receipt. Okay, let's jump on down the whole to sandwiches. Let's keep going with this.
Wikipedia has a list devoted to American sandwiches. The only sandwich whose ingredients are a mystery on this list is the Diablo sandwich. Diablo sandwich. So here we go. You'll each have a chance to answer this multiple choice question. In what hit 1970s movie does someone order a Diablo sandwich a
Love story be the Poseidon event adventure or see smoky and the bandit Well, I say smoky in the bandit. Okay Poseidon adventure. Okay, just guessing the deal I was gonna say five easy pieces because there was that great scene where Jack Nicholson does the sandwich a bit, huh? Oh yeah. I'm going to say love story just so we each take one. I like that move. Sean, you got it.
It's mostly in the band. Oh my God. If Willard won that one, we would never hear the end of it. He'd be the king hole. That's what we're playing for, to be the king hole. Hole king. Hole king. What was your handle in king whole. Whole king. Whole king. What was your handle in high school?
Whole king. Whole king. Whole king. Whole king. So Sheriff Justice, played by Jackie Gleason, orders a diablo sandwich. Yeah, it's a very funny scene I watched the last time. When I get home, I'm gonna hit your mama right in the mouth. That was it.
You know what he says? Something like that. There's no way you could come from my loins. Good. So who won Darcy? Okay, my little mouse will tell me the score in five seconds and I'll get a little. You guys, Will is the winner with six points.
Wow. Jason and Sean, you both had five. You were so goddamn close. Wow. But what does one get when they win or lose on the wiki hole? You're gonna love this. You get a generous donation made in your name to Wikipedia.
I like that. Oh, that's good. They're always looking. Which is great, right? Because they're always looking. Yeah, we need that. And you're never actually saying yes. You're always kind of Xing it up.
And now I can feel less guilty for just clicking through. Exactly. Yeah, that's exactly right. Very good. Okay, guys, I have one more question for you. Yeah. What is Henry Winkler's favorite sandwich? The hoagie?
I want to say a shark sandwich. That's what I want to say, but it's still... I'm gonna say, you mean the jumping the shark sandwich? Yeah, you know. I would say the hollowed out bagel. Mm, you think he'd hollow out a bagel? No, I don't want to put my finger in it. I've had it at his house with him before.
Yeah, okay. Well, to get the answer, we have a very special message from a very special guest. Hi, Jason Willen, Sean. It's Henry Winkler with the answer to my favorite sandwich. There are two parts. The first is a tuna sandwich with mayo, ketchup,
and finely diced onions on Wonder Bread. Part two is the day after Thanksgiving sandwich, Wonder Bread again, see the bridge. Mayo, turkey, fried stuffing, cranberry sauce out of the can, none of that berry crap. And then Wonder Bread. Hey, Dars, what is it like actually being a guest on the show and then, you know, instead of just being a question, you know, I had two of them at my dining room table and the tall one, you know, that third guy,
I helped him get his Tony. You know what, Dars, You're in a new podcast, Wiki-Hole, and I could bring one or both sandwiches if I were a guest on that podcast. There you go. What a sweet podcast. How great is that? We love it. We love it. I mean, if I could put him in a sandwich, I'd snack on him all day, every day.
Oh, delicious. He's the nicest man in show business. Oh, yeah. I've got an issue with his Wonder Bread addiction though, darn it. I want him around for hundreds of years. I know, I know. What is it that? But it is delicious. It is delicious.
Okay, quickly. I'm going to retrace the whole. We started with tuna fish sandwich, which led us to American sandwiches, which then led us to Smoky and the Bandit, which led us to Henry Wink the Bandit, which led us to Henry Winkler and right back to tuna fish sandwiches. I mean, how about one of his sandwiches with tuna fish sandwiches? I love that. I know. He's a smart guy. The full episodes go, we go a little bit deeper into these wiki holes.
It's super fun. You're gonna love it. Play along with us. We can't wait and and my three brothers, I'd love to have you on the full whole. We would love it. See you at the whole. See you at the whole. See you at the whole. So many times I've gotten that. Now listen, this is information we need to know.
It premieres Monday, March 4th, wherever you get your new podcast and new episodes are released every week. Or you can hear it a week early on Amazon Music or the Wondery app starting Monday, February 26th. Monday, February 26th, you say. Monday, February 26th, is that what you said? Monday, February 26th, you say. Oh, the 26th of February is when WikiHole is gonna start.
WikiHole with Darcy Cardin. Is at the end of February, specifically on the 26th, I think, is the early week on Amazon Wondery. And for everybody on March 4th. I love that, yeah. Free wherever you get your podcasts. March 4th wide. To RC, we love you.
We can't wait for the new show. Thank you for being part of the family and smartless media. You guys, I love you so much. Thank you for doing this. Thank you so much for having me. This is so fun. Bye guys. Bye.
Bye. If you like smartless, you can listen early and add free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple Podcasts. Prime members can listen add free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com. shirts, played by HBO's industries, Myhalla Harald, a brilliant scholarship student who has to quickly adapt to her newfound eat or be eaten world. Ava's ambitions take hold and her small town values break in hopes of becoming the first scholarship
student to make the list. Bishop Gray is all coveted academic top ten, curated by the headmaster himself. But after realizing she has no chance at the list on her own, she reluctantly accepts an invitation to a secret underground society that pulls the strings on campus life and academic success. If she bends to their will, she'll have everything she's ever dreamed of. But at what cost? Academy takes you into the world of a cutthroat private school where power, money, and sex collide in a game of life and death. Follow Academy on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts.
You can binge all episodes of Academy early and ad-free right now by joining Wondery Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.